[Music]
hey the libs are back
we're all together how did you how was
your vacation from us uh whatever you
call us
the rads
the like the post-modern edge lords i
just called them the ace beats really
you went and talked to like a right-wing
guy yeah it was fun we had our interview
with
um a bunch of people actually like
watching them and greg yeah
nate yes well we are
we've reassembled the avengers from our
uh
solo solo films
and uh yeah we're back we're back for
another
yeah we only have to tolerate each other
for one hour and 15 minutes are riveting
one hour and 15 minutes we have for you
today indeed
so we're talking about wittgenstein and
here's what i was thinking about
wittgenstein who matt will call
wittgenstein he knows the correct
pronunciation but he will still refuse
to do it he chooses to do it just just
because that's what he likes
issue a language acknowledgement at the
beginning of this some kind of speech
acknowledgement
yeah i would prefer not to that's the
thing i will call him what i want to
call him matt would like to acknowledge
that uh that it is pronounced
wittgenstein but yet he will choose to
continue to call it him vic wickenstein
he's lucky that i don't just call him mr
w so yeah he's moving to america so he's
practicing not pronouncing anything
correctly yeah yeah yeah
uh van
wykenstein weichenstein and pronounced
for the listeners we have to now to get
into our zoom call a click a land
acknowledgement from the institution
which is hosting the zoom call and we
were just kind of talking about this the
speech act of
land acknowledgement and how it's purely
a speech act we're still going to accrue
the value of the property that we you
know we stole your land but you don't
get it back
yeah and it's interesting that my
institution doesn't do that that's like
a new thing i've never seen without
naming institutions uh it's the first
time i've seen it where it pops up and
you have to agree not only do you have
to like see that lane acknowledgement
but you also have to like say accept
like agree with it it's like a little
language game a compelled
a compelled language game with no
material effect oh my god you sound like
jordan peterson right now i wonder if it
is compelled speech
example of a language game that we're
all kind of starting to play these days
land acknowledgements
i mean i guess i guess they'd have to
have a particular use we'll get we'll
get into
he gives different examples that we
could stein does
i think matt and i disagree on
wittgenstein but i'm gonna open up with
my take you know when a lefty suddenly
decides you know they've had it with
cancel culture
and then they go over to the right and
they're like i used to be a leftist they
begin every sentence with that i'm sure
there's examples i don't really know
them but gabriel basically dave rubin
over the comic section of youtube yeah
and they're they're welcomed in to their
to their grift over there and they get
money from all the uh the peterson's
sons elon musk actually pulled off
something fairly similar recently uh
when he went on his big ira being like i
voted democrat my entire life because i
thought they were the nice party but now
cancel culture is a threat to
civilization and i'm going to vote
republican for the first time in my life
and
more or less everybody on the left was
like bye
if you did if you did that
your income yeah your income would
probably go like like uh increase by a
factor of five if you decided to become
a right-wing grifter anyway it's only a
matter of time we're gonna we're gonna
get in the aisle we're gonna run out of
philosophers that are leftist and then
we'll have to switch over to uh
dugan yeah
anyway i brought up this example because
wittgenstein was on the analytics
the analytic team
and he was the champion of the act of
the analytic team bertrand russell said
he's uh
perhaps the most perfect example of a
genius that i've ever known
and then wittgenstein switched and said
you know what analytic philosophy is
[ __ ] so
we welcome him with open arms and uh
then bertrand russell said
oh i got another quote he said um
the later wittgenstein seems to have
grown tired of serious thinking and to
have invented a doctrine which would
make such an activity unnecessary
pills is of course referring to the
famous distinction between early
wittgenstein and late [ __ ] stein the
wickenstein of the tractatus and the
wickenstein of philosophical
investigations
wittgenstein's rebut was also you should
have
you should color code all of bertrand
russell's books all of the ones on
mathematics should be required reading
and everything on ethics
and politics should be in blue and then
they should all be burned or something
like that all the blue ones
well this this guy i mean you can you
can just search online for good videos
that describe his life but this guy
lived a pretty interesting life and was
a pretty interesting guy in his own
right he's very strange he was he was
born into a
incredibly rich family like
rich obscenely like even even beyond the
rockefellers beyond any of those they
were obscenely rich i i heard a story he
gave all his money away like it's just
very straight he gave away his entire
inheritance like you just get things
like that in his life that are like whoa
this guy is he also he also tried to
move to the soviet union to just be a
worker and they like tried to get him to
be a professor i think and he was like
no i just want to be a worker
yeah like he voluntarily enlisted in the
army he's he's crazy just give you a
sense of the scale of how wealthy he was
i was reading a biography of wittenstein
it wasn't the raymond one but it was
another one
where he was taking a vacation in sweden
and he had
he didn't travel first class he didn't
even have a trained carriage he had a
train uh just for him and his friends
like that'll give you a sense of like
how mega wealthy this guy was you know
it's the equivalent of having you know a
private jet uh or even a fleet of
private jets just at your beck and y'all
yeah and cambridge
the building of cambridge to him was
like his living room like it's
his this guy was just on another planet
with how wealthy his family was the the
wittgenstein family they were obscenely
wealthy but
ludwig himself was given to some strange
behavior very much had a kind of purity
almost like a messiah complex going with
his towards his philosophy he would
often isolate himself
in really really far away places like he
would go to norway i think he started
the tractatus in norway and he would
stay in little huts out in the middle of
nowhere and even the people who live
in the middle of nowhere on the way to
his hut would be like whoa dude why are
you going out that far that's the middle
of nowhere like this guy was a real kind
of aesthetic i guess the best way to
describe him is gives away all his money
focuses his life on obtaining truth and
how to get to truth and
this guy is was just a strange dude i
like him though and not great people
skills by all accounts no no and he he
also he also designed a house too like
he he got into like architecture and
interior design for a while and like
designed a house for one of his sisters
i think
and it took him so long because he was
so obsessive about every single detail
like even like the height between like
where the door handle is and like the
bottom and like the way the windows open
and he would spend like months at a time
just like obsessing over like each of
these fine details oh yeah he went into
engineering and aeronautics at first he
even designed a jet engine like he he
did all kinds of stuff like that too
terry eagleton uh who actually uh
produced a movie on wickenstein that was
quite good
um
eccentric but quite good uh tilda
swinton's in it uh had this related this
kind of curious anecdote where
cambridge was kind of in a weird
situation at the beginning uh and the
middle of the 20th century where they
were just starting to accept some
working class um applicants and giving
them scholarships to study there and
apparently
people got furious at him because
whenever
wickenstein had a working-class student
who would come in
because they were trying to aspire to a
kind of higher quality of life by coming
to an institution of this caliber he'd
sit there and be like why are you doing
that you should just go back and work in
your motorcycle factory because that was
much more pure quality of life than what
you found here it was a mistake for your
parents to send you here so then you
have all these working-class students
just going back to their houses being
like well i talked to like the greatest
living philosopher at cambridge and he
told me that what we're doing is just
fine and the parents would just write
these furious letters to cambridge being
like the [ __ ] are you doing like we
saved money for decades to send her son
here and now you're telling me that we
shouldn't bother to begin with like the
hell
yeah he was known for having little
strategies to thin out his students like
that
he's one of the first ideas don't matter
philosophers
yeah yeah it's true i mean i think it's
interesting that pills you kind of said
he
switched teams
and i think like he probably wouldn't i
don't even know if like was the analytic
continental divide like the way that
they framed it back then like i know
because it's not like he started reading
heidegger and stuff like that he just
kind of was like i'm not a fan i'm not
going to care about like logical
foundations
or at least they're like not going to be
findable so you know but i think a lot
of analytic philosophers still kind of
claim them i always remember this story
when i was an undergrad i had this like
really eccentric like swiss italian
professor eros karatza and he would
always talk [ __ ] so he was a philosopher
of language and he would always like
warn his undergrad students he'd be like
wittgenstein is very important but you
have to be careful because he gets
co-opted by french bullshitters
[Laughter]
his last his last work on uncertainty
one of the one of something derived from
lectures near the end of his life that's
been interpreted as an
anti-enlightenment statement because he
he talks about the the enlightenment
demand for certainty and he believed
that certainty was never possible and so
that's taken as a kind of post-modern
like very early post like the 50s might
even be too way too early for
talking about post-modernism in in
philosophy but he seemed to be almost
like a precursor in that sort of way
he questioned certainty in his later
career but earlier on obviously in the
tractatus and his work with
russell he was very much in the logical
positivist tradition
which is is a new land that i am
parachuting into so take take what i say
with a grain of salt but i'm on the
journey
have you guys tried to read the
tractatis
yeah
i mean i read about 30 pages of it but
it was brutal yeah if you're not
familiar with the logical notation then
a lot of the technical details um aren't
really of much value but i think the
overall message is really interesting
and
there's no doubt that like
a lot of it is actually just beautifully
written i mean there are passages in it
that are
not just evocative but i would say
haunting like people tend to remember
very distinctly even the deduction but
certainly the ending passages uh about
what of what one cannot speak one must
pass over in silence or the opening kind
of assertion that the world is all that
is the case um i think it's like a
beautiful book in a lot of ways yeah he
was a great stylist
wittgenstein himself hated it and only
referred to the author himself in third
person
by the end of his life and
rejected it he wrote he wrote critiques
of his own book several
yeah i mean and people pointed out that
in some ways he is
distinct in the history of philosophy in
that respect because while most
philosophers who have lengthy careers
can be periodized you talk about the
early heidegger or the late heidegger
but wittgenstein developed two pretty
distinct philosophies which are quite
fundamentally incompatible with one
another although i would argue that
there is an overlap in fact a very
serious overlap between uh the two
outlooks and
very much uh in keeping with like the
spirit of what pills was talking about
because i think the one continuous theme
you see throughout his work is the idea
that philosophy
doesn't really matter all that much it's
a kind of idle
unimportant discipline
and he just goes about proving that in
very different ways in the early period
and the late period
that quote you brought up is really
central
just to establish kind of because i'm
sure there's people listening who have
never heard of this guy before but we're
talking about
kind of eric's area actually but logic
plus language plus truth how does
language lead to truth how do you use
language can language even get to truth
and then how do we use language and and
play it in different areas of life
so
wittgenstein wrote this best book of
analytic philosophy of language
which is early wittgenstein and then
late wittenstein he becomes more of a
i think the term that's usually used as
he's a philosopher of everyday life or
everyday language and the meaning of
language comes from its practical use
the way ordinary people use it and the
philosophers what they have to say about
language is most of the time
wrong
so that's our that's our division split
here
yeah yeah i'd like to put it even more
basically which is if you've seen that
scene in arrival where
the guy um
is telling you know the linguist like
look just ask him the question like why
are you here it's really straightforward
we don't need you to like diddle daddle
around with like all this word [ __ ] and
she sits there and she's like okay and
then underwear it's a word why and it's
like so what does exactly this mean you
know it could be that i'm asking them a
motivation question it could also mean
that i'm asking them a verbal question
about the basis for their action then
kind of goes through that wittenstein is
that kind of guy where you want to ask
yourself these big highfalutin questions
and he's always there saying
i'm not exactly sure that we're even
capable of doing that at least not in
the kind of way that philosophers who
don't pay attention to language want to
be able to ask those questions
yeah i'm going to let i'm going to let
eric give me some of the frame here but
uh philosophical investigations opens up
with what wittgenstein calls
the kind of western view of
of philosophy and language and he quotes
augustine saint augustine and
augustine's theory of language of course
it's written in whatever 300.
um kind of rudimentary he says there are
things in the world and there are names
of those things in the world and then we
group up sentences of names and that's
what language is
i think we're
if if we're gonna begin by looking at
his later stuff i i tried to just get a
broad overview when i was trying when i
was researching this so i didn't focus i
think it would be better to kind of
start early and then move forward don't
you think because it's hard to
understand the later work unless you
understand what he's responding to it's
not true yeah
look look look i'm playing host duty so
here's my strategy for this we're going
to open up with his opening
from yeah a later book but that whole
opening of the later book
brings up first of all what is this
overview western understanding of what
language is beginning with augustine
and then he'll go on to say oh and by
the way i finished off that view i i
brought that view as far as it could go
so i think if we just start
with the kind of
what has language been thought to be
one end of that he puts himself as the
bookend and then he brings it into
somewhere completely different so yes i
am starting with a late book but he's
talking about
he's giving a historical overview and
putting himself in it that's why i
brought that up and of course the
the common view would be
this representational or correspondence
theory and then his new
and then his own contradiction of that
is going to be with something called
language games yeah
yeah well language games yeah when you
you that really indicates his later work
but if you
look at his earlier work the the main
thing is his picture theory of language
that's what runs through the tractatus
and the the picture theory of language
is is something he sort of develops off
of the basis of of you know principia
mathematica whitehead and russell's
three-volume works um
i'm not sure if the all three volumes
are out but by the time he was reading
them but he he wrote
that early work the tractatus over seven
years right
during the 1910s it was published just
before 19 or around 1920
and then he kind of just [ __ ] off and
like went and left
cambridge and left england for a long
time and didn't come back but that
didn't go to austria and like beat
school children
yeah like he got involved in world war
one he was he volunteered to fight he
then he wanted to become a school
teacher and he taught elementary
level students for a while which is
but constantly i saw in his letters he's
constantly complaining about austria
being very sort of the people are all
disheartened and nobody seems to have
any kind of spirit he can't talk to
anybody he felt very isolated
but that's all background information
that the tractatus is really like this
picture theory of language where
where pictures correspond to states of
affairs what he calls facts
and uh i mean
you gotta you really gotta know if you
wanna read this book you've gotta be
really familiar with the logical
notation that that bertrand russell and
and um
and alfred white had come up with for
their for their uh
principia mathematica
so it's you know the tractatus you know
if you take any couple things from it so
far from what i've seen you should take
that it's based on this
picture theory
which
ramsay describes a in his review of it
uh ramsay's another young brilliant guy
from cambridge he says a picture is a
fact
and as such has a structure and a form
you know so it
has a there's a form of representation
and that makes possible structure of
representation
and the
the elements of the representation
correspond to the elements or objects
involved in the fact so it was a kind of
correspondence theory of truth as well
in his picture theory and of course matt
brought up that very important quote um
you know
we can say
uh very roughly paraphrasing it you know
there are certain things we can put in
the form of philosophical propositions
logical propositions and there are
certain things we cannot put into
logical propositions those things that
we cannot those are things we must
remain silent on
so and
and wittgenstein kind of
said he'd completed all of the problems
of philosophy after this tractatus that
was his self-evaluation of the work is
that he had finished philosophy that he
solved all the problems and that now we
could get on to other things because the
tractatus solved all the problems
what you cannot speak of in the form of
logical propositions according to the
picture theory
those are just things that we can't
speak about they're they're the silence
they're the they're something you know
religion values ethics
all sorts of things right he was kind of
a semanticist at this point before he
became interested in pragmatics of
language later in his life right well
this is why i want to say i think the
book is something of a literary
masterpiece though because it is
structured in an extraordinary way
in
a sense that is later books are not
because they're all published
posthumously and other people had to
organize them and they were never
completed to his satisfaction but what's
remarkable about this book
is he runs through this brilliant
logical argument talking about the
picture theory of language basically
describing how it is that words can hook
on to the world and provides you with
the correspondence theory not just of
language but of knowledge and then at
the end of it he says if you really
think about it what's interesting about
my book is the fact that
my philosophy itself is nonsensical
according to the terms that i've laid
out within it because what i'm doing
isn't describing a state of affairs in
the world but describing how it is that
language can represent a state of
affairs in the world which is not the
same kind of thing ergo my approach is
rather like a ladder that's the metaphor
he uses so once you understand how
pointless this entire exercise i just
engaged in is i dropped the ladder aside
and you can see more clearly and what
you also recognize as eric put it very
beautifully is that a lot of the kind of
things that i just described as
nonsensical
ethics aesthetics religion
all the kind of stuff that we really
want to know about can never be said
according to this philosophy which is
another reason why we should chuck this
philosophy and just dedicate ourselves
with a kind of quiet dignity uh towards
approaching life with an aesthetic and
ethical sensibility uh that can never be
put in the terms that are demanded by
certainty uh and a lot of people didn't
really get this snake-like quality to
the book where it eventually swallows uh
itself at the end
and he allegedly got into these huge
arguments with people at the vienna
school who appreciated the first two
thirds of it and said yeah we really
want to carry on with exactly this
project just tinker a bit around the
edges
and he said you know you've entirely
missed the point of it you shouldn't be
reading people like popper uh or
following all this kind of scientific bs
read dostoevsky and kierkegaard instead
they'll tell you where the real action
in life is
and you know they were all just like
who are you exactly you're not exactly
the guy that we thought you were going
to be
yeah he put he picked up a book during
the war right that tolstoy i think he
picked up a tolstoy book during the war
and it changed him and and sort of
shifted him into a more
uh into being interested in questions of
mystical and religious topics he
famously said that kierkegaard was the
deepest person who had ever lived far
too deep for him uh and kind of made the
same kind of comment that dostoyevsky
may or sorry toast nietzsche made about
dostoyevsky that kierkegaard was far too
deep for him and he was one of the few
people that he could learn from in terms
of his own personal philosophy of life
and
it's really quite telling right but
again i think the book is a literary
masterpiece because it really does end
on this remarkable kind of
self-swallowing moment
where
you are just amazed at the kind of
intellectual audacity of what's been
achieved and then he seemed
immediately willing to discard it and
saying why bother with that let's move
on to something else well i was just
gonna say i i think one thing that would
be
interesting to maybe do actually in a
future episode if we want to do more
wittgenstein is like because what he
ends up going with i think in the
investigations
is to basically argue that when you do
an analysis of like the way language
functions in everyday life a lot of the
traditional philosophical problems
of like the history of philosophy
dissolve and that's what a lot of people
call like the therapeutic approach to
philosophy which is all which i think is
kind of an interesting
topic in itself that could be explored
which is like in what way is philosophy
therapeutic
rather than trying to like find
fundamental questions of reality
instead it's supposed to
you know and i find it interesting that
he would use that language
you know uh
act as a kind of therapy so we can stop
stressing because i think that one of
the things given his personality type
that drove wittgenstein crazy was like
this thirst for truth and that he can
like settle the questions and then he
and then when he realized he couldn't
it makes sense to me that he'd be like
well no so philosophy is not about truth
anymore it's about therapy it's about
making me not have to worry about these
dumb problems like what is truth you
know what is reality like these these
questions that he uh he describes as
being language going on holidays right
that you're using language in a way
where it's not tied to its everyday use
and that's what he thinks philosophy
traditionally is like asking these weird
questions that don't belong
um that make us think there's like this
deep question to be solved but really we
need to do philosophy to make us realize
that there is no question there that
it's just
and you know that might be an episode
topic of its own but i thought it's kind
of an interesting shift
uh and i think a lot of the shift can be
framed as kind of psychological in a way
and one of the
one of the most common quotes or uh
statements that he made was if we
understood what language actually is
i don't know if he says 90 i have it in
my head as 90 but he said 90 of
philosophy would just disappear into a
relevance if we actually understood what
we're doing with the material there and
of course anyone who read the first
two-thirds of the track tattus
uh doesn't want to hear in the last
chapter oh by the way um it's done now
and that was [ __ ]
yeah yeah and i mean i will say there's
a really famous anecdote um
that i think is true because rey monk
and terry eagleton both pointed out
which is apparently pierrot strafa had
been reading gramsci at the time uh and
when wickedstein was defending his
picture theory of language to strafa i
think it was strafa uh straphel kind of
gave him the middle finger and he's like
what is the picture behind this and it
drove wickenstein nuts because he just
wasn't able to figure out a way to
actually
link that to his theory in a way that
would settle the whole thing and
apparently went off on around
of threatening to kill himself unless he
could actually figure out the way to
incorporate uh the meaning behind this
gesture into the picture theory of
language and then decided to give it up
there is a kind of through line between
his earlier and later stuff in the sense
that when you read the tractatus you get
the sense that you know all of
philosophy's problems are caused by
words being used with different meanings
right equivocation through words he
thinks that's where most of
philosophical issues come from
so
you know he
words
are
a kind of
component of propositions and in that
first phase in the tractatus
he wants to take all the propositions
and reduce them to
a kind of atomic a set of atomic
propositions
which would point to these atomic facts
you can then this is sort of russell's
logical atomism coming through so there
is already a sense that all of
philosophy's problems come through
equivocation in the use of words and we
have to understand words if you know if
you walk into a room and just say green
hat bug like you can't use disconnected
words you have to form propositions
subject predicate saying something about
something and then later on
you know you get the more sense that
the equivocation comes from
what gilbert ryle will call category
mistakes where you use words from one
language game and you mix them up with
words from another language game so you
can i i heard this great example you can
you can describe the game of cricket the
british game of cricket right as it
bowlers
it has wickets it has the batter it has
the the mound it has all that stuff
but then you talk about but then what
about team spirit and then they're okay
you have a category mistake team spirit
is not a part of the game team spirit is
part of a different language game and if
you try to bring team spirit into the
description of cricket you're going to
be making this category mistake and so
one of the things is to separate
language into these individual language
games what is teen
team spirit a teen spirit nirvana what i
don't get what you mean not nirvana i
don't get what you mean by the
connection though
you mean the cricket players have team
spirit
well that's the that's the problem right
it doesn't make sense in the context of
the game of cricket what is the game of
cricket as players as batters as these
this and that does it have team spirit
no because that's a totally different
that's a totally different language game
when we're discussing things like
motivation team spirit cohesiveness
those that's a different language game
it's a category mistake to say team
spirit is part of the description of
what
cricket is
what you find with this argument that we
do in kind of philosophical anthropology
is a kind of anti-essentialist claim uh
not just about you know what it is that
language does but also about who human
beings are
because it's rejecting the idea that we
have what we're decard a kind of glassy
essence uh and that the primary thing we
do with language is just paint a
description of the world a picture of
the world if you will uh wickenstein
says that sometimes that is what we're
doing with words we're just describing
the world uh and we're trying to
describe it as accurately as possible uh
but that's not what we're doing we're
playing a language game like going on a
date with someone and talking about how
you feel about them or even describing a
game of football right that you might
happen to witness uh but also talking
about how you felt at the game right
there are different kind of
uses that we put words to in those
circumstances and so again the job of
philosopher then is to just engage in a
kind of higher order reflection uh on
the different way that these games are
played
but not to criticize them uh or to say
that they're not representing the world
accurately just to understand the
meaning that these different words
assume in these forms of life well it
isn't isn't but isn't the broader point
that he's making that like
the picture theory of language
has like a tries to offer like a logical
positivist account of like what language
is that there's like
but then i think that like what he's
trying to do later is to be like well
you're not going to find the answer of
like what language is in its essence by
just looking at it as like logical
positivism which is i thought where he
comes in with like
the meaning of a language is is the is
to uh to understand the form of life and
like form of life is i think this an
important concept and like he makes a
couple moves in the investigation to
kind of argue why like
your kind of logical positivist story of
language is just being like a symbol to
like describe the world breaks down
and that like language is actually
rooted to like an inner subjective
social
element that like you can't talk about
language without talking about that
and like that's where for example
something like the private language
which maybe it's too much to get into
now but i know pills you sent us a
little summary about private language
and basically what he's doing there is
just saying that like
it would be impossible to come up with a
private language in your mind where only
you knew the meanings of the words
because fundamentally language requires
another to to to have reciprocity with
the and like one of the ways he argues
for that is he says
how would you even know that that was
the meaning of the word that you decided
you might forget if it's private there's
no
uh criteria of reliability that you need
another it has to be social otherwise
it's meaningless
i just want to slow this down and just
get to the term
language game it's the main term and it
will kind of explicate this
so this
represent representational view of
language that we have words that refers
to a world
that is never going to get at what the
essence are not i shouldn't say that
where that's actually wrong word it
won't get to the meaning of words if we
want to find out what the meaning of
words are we need to look at how they're
used and how they're being used at a
specific time so he gives like 60
examples of different language games and
philosophy is one of those philosophy is
not like to be thrown out it's an
activity it has its rules
analytic philosophy is like
doing a sudoku puzzle i guess
but also when you go into a bar to order
a beer that's also a language game and
they have
different rules so
it's it's not rude
to just walk up to a bartender and start
the sentence um
yo can i get a miller light
in any other context you know your wife
comes home from work if the first thing
you said to her was uh
yo can i get a miller light
it would it wouldn't work in that game
that game would fall apart but if you're
ordering a miller light you're probably
an [ __ ] anyway so maybe if you're
living in like sunnydale trailer park uh
that wouldn't be like out of uh
like on keeping but i want to say
absolutely yeah and no i'm not done yet
i'm not done yet it's not just about
rudeness and
and acceptability it's about
like there is a code that makes things
sensible in contexts that you can't just
move to a different context
and his critique the general critique of
this representational
kind of uh language use
you could just call the whole history of
philosophy is pretty pretty much that of
course there's exceptions but it's like
we're sitting there
in our chair wondering what is a concept
and then giving a whole bunch of
explanations definitions of what a
concept is furnishing it with examples
and then you have like a descartes book
for example
but what descartes is doing according to
vicki's time late wittenstein is taking
all these other words that belong to
different language games where their
meaning is quite clear like miller lite
has a very
clear meaning
and then trying to move them all over
into philosophy and then they're
bastardized they're taken out of their
home and then you can basically do
whatever you want with them and it's not
useless sometimes you can get like uh
insights or
interesting theories from from doing
that but you're never gonna get to what
is language if you only do philosophy
you just you have to go to a bar
there you go yeah and i think again
there's a nice anti-foundationless
dimension to this because i think that
you're right and saying that one can do
philosophy if one is willing to be a
kind of humble philosopher and engage in
the kind of philosophical anthropology
that you're just describing right asking
yourself what is the meaning of the word
mineral miller light in the context of
going to the bar and off and asking for
frankly a mediocre beer right but the
problem in the history of philosophy as
he understands it uh and philosophical
investigations has some ruminations on
this although it becomes clear in
uncertainty is that philosophy can have
this kind of imperial ambition where
what the philosopher will do is either
try to appropriate the different words
from different forms of life and say
this is what people think they mean but
this is what they really mean if we
break them down and analyze them
carefully enough or even worse it'll say
things like people are going to church
and they're talking about things like
god or the soul
and they're making metaphysical or
cosmological claims to that in that
respect and these are actually just
nonsensical claims uh they're basically
doing
from a pop-paring perspective let's use
that example shitty science and
wickenstein is going to say no if you
look at the claims made by somebody who
is talking about the book of genesis in
church and say they're just doing shitty
science like richard dawkins right then
you fundamentally misunderstand he
thinks at least that they're just
playing a very different kind of
language game than what richard dawkins
is doing when he's writing a book about
selfish genes or stephen hawking is
doing when he's writing about uh black
holes well isn't also one of the points
though that like
to get like more concrete about like
philosophical problems that he thinks
are like kind of nonsense and a result
of language it's like
okay like you use this word truth or you
use this word mind in everyday language
to like refer to something really
specific that's like contextual
to like oh i'm losing my mind and it
means
you know that like you're all out of
sorts and you're confused or like you
you know but then you know philosophers
come about and be like well what is mind
what is it
right and then like i think one of the
points that wittgenstein is trying to
make by dissolving these philosophical
problems is to be like
no there's no mystery here
like like you the way that you're posing
that question is making it seem like
there's some ontological question of
like what is a mind
when really it's just a word that's
being used in specific context to mean
something very contextual and
philosophers are coming along and
[ __ ] it up just like truth right like
yeah that's it truth like a lot of more
modern philosophers who are definitely
inspired by wittgenstein
take this approach to like
deflationary approach to be like there
is no philosophical confusion here
you're just confusing you're using the
word in a different context like simon
blackburn i think has this deflationary
view of truth and he says
you know to understand what truth is all
you need to ask is like what's at stake
here
like is it like so for example you could
just say
you know whatever this person is guilty
of murder
and you don't need to say is true at the
end of that statement
because all you need to say is the
statement itself but then philosophers
come in and be like oh there's this
property that is truth that's like a
mystery that we like have to understand
and i think vikkensteinian uh inspired
approaches to philosophy say that that
doesn't that that's just a confusion
over like how the words are used in
different language games and truth just
means something contextual and it's
there's not going to be some capital t
truth uh that's just like a weird
confusion as a result of our misusing
language i think and it's not even it's
not even philosophy's job to
look at the truth of statements right
like that famous example the cat is on
the mat
right the point of that is that the
logical structure of that proposition
would mirror the logical structure of
the fact right of a fact
is a state of affairs
and so the state of affairs would be
mirrored in the statement the cat is on
the mat and the role of philosophy is
really just to clarify the use of words
so a question like
just to expand what victor was saying a
question like what the me what is the
meaning of life like that kind of
question
it's not that that question is not
important it's it's actually even more
that question is meaningless it has
there's no sense to that question and
that this is the early wicked stein
because there's no empirical
verifiability
to
the question of what is the meaning of
life you can't bring it into an
empirical analysis
but later on i imagine wittgenstein
would say questions like what is the
meaning of life or you know that would
be like a language game you'd play in a
religious setting you get
you'd be discussing the meaning of life
in
you know a religious context but in a
scientific context that question doesn't
come on because science still uses
empirical observations and principles of
verification it's a totally different
language game if you ask a scientist to
solve the question of what is the
meaning of life they can't do it they
might try to do it but but really it's
not part of their language game and
you'd be confusing categories and mixing
up words from different language games
and then creating that confusion again
that the whole project is supposed to
dispel
i i would argue though that even in the
tractatus you do see
this kind of attitude uh so for instance
you know he has these remarkable
ending sentences where he talks about
how in the tractatus the answer to the
riddle of space and time is to be found
outside of space and time right and so
one of the ways that we can kind of
approach the question of the meaning of
life is to recognize that the quest for
certainty uh on the meaning of life
is itself meaningless and that the
closer you get the more you'll realize
that the whole endeavor is
senseless you know the router that you
have to throw away
and so
once you've kind of come to the
standpoint uh you can coach
questions uh like what should i set
myself towards uh with a level of wisdom
uh and a capacity for self-reflection
that you didn't have before right so
again i would even interpret the
tractatus as witkenstein offering a kind
of therapeutic aid to people who need
certainty on the question of what the
meaning of life is because it kind of
shows you that this is as close as you
can get and then you realize you're
never going to get there when it comes
to all the important things so just drop
it right move on uh dissolve the kind of
problem and what he says in the
philosophical investigations is that
this is a kind of nonsensical way of
looking at things that the idea that you
can just create ever more philosophical
rules that will tell you how to use
words properly so you can kind of move
from
a very
general level of speaking about things
to a particular level uh while speaking
about things with absolute certainty uh
it's never going to come about because
there are a wide variety of different
rules that you can use when speaking
about things and he makes the argument
that these are set by
social uh demands not by anything like
an aspiration towards truth or or
certainty
so you know again use pills example of
miller light when i ask myself how can i
be certain i will get a miller light if
you just go to some random person on the
street and say give me a miller light
then we know because of social rules
that that person is going to say what
the [ __ ] are you doing right and we'd
say that if you want to get a miller
light you go to a bar and there is a
rule and that social setting that if you
make the statement i would like a miller
lite the bartender will give it to you
but that's not a true statement uh a
rule that gets you closer to the truth
of something
it's just in recognition that this is
the social convention that we've
established when it comes to the use of
those words in that particular situation
so philosophy or at least the philosophy
of language is
in this sense kind of parasitical
on common life everyday life but then
pretends like it's not and then it calls
itself you know the queen of the
sciences or or whatever
and that's just he's saying if you ask
like how do we get to truth in language
you've already
shot yourself in the foot that's there's
no answer to that question that's not
what language is for
and i just wanted to bring up with
respect to
rules and why he says language games in
the first place
it's kind of a nightmare to come up if
you if you ask
we're talking about what is truth what
is the meaning of life all these deep
questions but he he just asked the
question what is a game
there's no way of answering the question
what is a game
because there are so many different
types of games there are you know card
games the olympic games
um if if kids are just throwing a ball
against a wall
that's also considered a game
and then the the first answer is well
it's something that there are rules to
and he he goes through the example of
every
possible response to what is a game
and kind of says well it doesn't apply
in this case doesn't apply in this case
like if
if a kids are throwing a ball against
the wall yeah it's a game are there any
rules there
no
if you're if you're playing a game
can i who can throw the ball the highest
it counts as a game i think everyone
would say
but
there's no rules there
um is a game fun
well if you're if it's your job are you
having fun with it is it always fun if
you're like one of these
dudes grinding um dota or something are
they having fun every single time they
play so anyway anytime you try to give
here's the final definition of game
you're always going to
find an exception to that rule and then
he says
this is where the term family
resemblances which i'm sure people have
heard with reference to to wittgenstein
is and he says the meaning of terms
comes in this vast
socially created network of resemblances
some things are true in one case not
another but it's a shifting
uh
vague
fuzzy
sort of
conceptual web that underscores language
not a clear picture as someone like
fraga would have said fergus said like
if you got a fuzzy concept then it's not
a real concept
and
wittgenstein's response to that is well
if you say
go stand
roughly over there
that's a completely acceptable use of
language to say go stand somewhere over
there and there's no clear reference
somewhere over there is not clear
so
that's where the that's why we say games
that's the other term family resemblance
which i would be remiss if we didn't
actually just touch on in this episode
yeah no that's important and i think um
you know there's
a word that actually i don't think has
come up yet is pragmatism and which i
know eric is you know heavily involved
and i think there's a way in which you
could call this eric's breathing faster
a pragmatic view of language in the
sense that like really what it's
pointing to is if you want to understand
language
you have to look at what is it doing
right like that's the whole point of
like connecting into forms of life
but i didn't want to actually point out
i was looking in the book i've got my
copy of the investigations right here
and i was looking for like one of my
favorite aphorisms which really speaks
to what pills was just talking about
and what i really like about it is
he's kind of
confessing his own
intellectual and psychological struggle
with what he was trying to do in the
tractatus and then what he realizes
he needs to do which is to like
really bring out the pragmatic use of
language the way it's connected to just
like everyday ways of doing things so
aphorism 107
he says the more closely we examine
actual language the greater becomes the
conflict between it and our requirement
for the crystalline purity of logic was
of course not something i had discovered
it was a requirement right so he's
saying he needed language to be logical
and then he says the the conflict
becomes intolerable the requirement is
now in danger of becoming vacuous we
have got onto slippery ice where there
is no friction and so in a certain sense
the conditions are ideal but also just
because of that we are unable to walk we
want to walk so we need friction
back to the rough ground
so i think what are you saying there
right it's like you're looking for this
logical structure where just like what
pills was talking about where like you
want to find the perfect reference to
everything but then when you like look
at it you're like well i can't do
anything with this like it's not
actually showing me
the the kind of truth about how language
functions which is like pragmatic
it's vague right that's the example that
pills use right go stand over there it's
like not giving you
so it's kind of rough right it's not
this beautiful pure structure because
it's so rooted in its context so
i think that's
uninteresting and and i and the
investigations by the way is full of
these examples
where
it's written in aphromis where you can
see him
kind of like coming to this admission
that what he was looking for before
doesn't make sense
and this emphasis on just like well look
at how the language actually works in
practice
yeah i i suggested earlier
that you could understand
what wittgenstein was doing in the
tractatus as a as a kind of semantics
whereas what he's doing in the in the
later work uh is a kind of pragmatics of
language right if you're familiar with
charles morris's famous distinction and
what was it uh syntactics semantics and
pragmatics right
focus on the first two leave pragmatics
out
wittgenstein moved into the pragmatics
sphere and his later
thing
and he read william james's
varieties of religious experience
and and he was in contact with other
people who were familiar with the
pragmatist tradition as well and i think
that influenced him after the tractatus
to move towards this you know meaning
instead of a picture theory of meaning
it's the meaning of words is meaning in
use
or he says most words anyway so
90 99 who knows yeah and there's there's
no social dimension to this uh because i
really like
his depiction of philosophers is
obsessed with making language into a
rule-governed activity uh and framing it
in that way you know you think about
somebody like kant
you can see kant is basically saying
well if you want to talk about empirical
objects then i've devised these rules
you have to follow them right you can't
just talk about things in themselves i'm
telling you that you need to describe
them
in
transcendental terms uh or you can think
about the logical positivist is doing
something that's analogous to this right
if you want to talk about
objects uh then they need to be talked
about we need to talk about objects of
sense we can't talk about nonsensical
things like
god or spirituality or aesthetics or
whatever all that's pushed aside and
the quote that victor is coming up with
uh is really nice because he's saying
why approach the study of language that
way why be somebody who's there to give
rules to social life especially because
that seems so removed from a lot of the
purposes that people actually use their
language for and it seems to be working
you know you go to the bar you want a
miller lite and you say i'd like a
middle of light please because you have
shitty taste and beer and lo and behold
all of a sudden you have one probably
five because that's what it takes to
enjoy it right
what's wrong with you you can only enjoy
the sixth
don't enjoy the sex yeah
like why sit there and
bring emanuel kant into this and have
him say well you know when he was
talking about that miller light he
wasn't really talking about a miller
light in and of itself he was talking
about the phenomena of miller light
there might be another light there but
there might not be
it just seems like kind of a waste of
time well i think also this is
this is why my one of my
professors in undergrad kind of like my
mentor into continental philosophy she
taught wittgenstein as a phenomenologist
the investigations at least like she
said that he was
you know that what he's doing is a
phenomenology of like the way language
actually
functions in practice that's i mean
that's a bit of another story but just
what you were saying there makes me
think about
um
just like see take it up on its own
terms right like what what is it doing
and i think that in a way is a
phenomenological task
and this is why he kind of i said at the
beginning oh he's on our team
because i kind of think he is in the
sense that like
it's not like philosophy ended because
wittgenstein was like you know all these
problems are fake but what the french
guys kind of connect with him in terms
of uh sembiotics what they connect with
him on is the emphasis becomes no longer
how do we use philosophy to describe
correctly describe the world the
question kind of shifts
to
what can we do
with language to
think better to make people think better
and that doesn't mean think more
accurately it means like
what is what is literature how do we
include literature in in philosophy so
i'm thinking of course of someone like
deliz deliz is like i'm going to use
language for everything it can do but
his concern is never like am i
accurately describe i mean that's not
fair to say
the main concern i should say is not am
i accurately describing the thing that
i'm purporting to describe with my uh
syllogisms
well i would say that there are
definitely analytical ways of taking
this up and in oxford oxbridge uh they
immediately did so with ordinary
language philosophy which produced i
think some very boring work personally
uh but it was important right and
they gave a very english approach to the
kind of deconstructive or deflationary
views of the world uh that you were
describing you know uh rm hare uh was a
moral theorist and derek parfit once
asked him like i'm concerned about the
meaning of life and arm hair was like
look around you do you see something
called meaning in any of the objects out
there do you see ordinary people
concerned about these questions of
meaning see meaning of life is no
problem stop wasting your time with like
sartre and all those other kind of
fruity french people and just focus on
analyzing propositions according to like
this ordinary language lens right so you
can definitely give this a kind of banal
uh reading in the sense that all we're
doing is trying to dissolve
philosophical public puzzles to more or
less leave the world as it is and
there's kind of conservative quality to
this i just think that the french
interpretation you're giving bills is
more interesting and more exciting uh
and probably also more keeping with the
spirit of wickenstein himself who
whatever else he was uh wasn't going to
become a nice bourgeois
kind of you know
word muncher you know he was always
going to have a deeper project
underpinning anything that he was doing
yeah if people took victory seriously
there would be no
philosophy department
he would do just read literature
yeah maybe maybe i don't know about that
but i was going to say though like on
this idea of him being like on our team
kind of i think i mean i think there's a
certain extent which i agree with that i
mean i think that's
true but i also think like
there are a whole bunch of and still who
consider themselves analytic
philosophers alive and dead
who we could also say are on our team
too because they do accept kind of that
anti-foundationalist like good examples
would be like donald davidson or like
john mcdowell like these are people who
are and very much and richard rory who's
i mean
he really did switch teams like even
like i would say self-described in a way
he switched teams
but there's like mcdowell
and davidson who are people who never
switch teams we're always analytic
philosophers but i think like in terms
of their philosophical commitments to
like what is the nature of language
and truth and foundations i think they
are on our team as well in the same way
that victim is yeah davidson just for an
example davidson
basically said all language is
metaphoric you you're you're never going
to get to the
underside of language
it's a which is something that's close
to you know deference or something like
that yeah i also
got the sense of kind of later
wittgenstein being
almost
parallel to certain continental themes
in various ways
but it's all very superficial in my head
right now i don't know because you know
like the early wittgenstein could be
compared to structuralism and their sort
of privileging of scientific discourse
it becomes a kind of master discourse
into which everything either has to be
dissolved or thrown out if it can't be
dissolved into it
and then later he seems to give license
to
the idea of well this idea of meaning in
use and language being a social
phenomenon
at its core
seems to give license to the more sort
of you know deridian
kind of spirit where
meaning is constantly deferred right you
never get there you never get to the end
point it kind of just keeps going round
and round in circles
and we can't get a sense of it we can't
get an idea of it it just kind of slips
between the cracks all the time
but i mean any any further than that i
don't think i could go i don't think
wittgenstein is completely skeptical of
that words
have meanings i think he believes words
have meanings
i think there's a bit of controversy
over whether wittgenstein actually
arrives at a kind of human skepticism or
whether that's just a kind of cheap
interpretation to kind of
hold wittgenstein back from going full
pomo
but um
otherwise i mean he does seem to lurch
very far in the direction of a kind of
you know critique of enlightenment
critique of meaning as kind of authorial
intent versus how meaning
works in the world
but beyond that you know i i can't
travel i i want to remain silent
i wonder whether uh an intro a good like
sequel episode to this would be because
i know though you know when i think
about that professor from my undergrad
who talked about being careful about the
french bullshitters i wonder if like the
good french bullshitter for us to look
at would be the very short book the
post-modern condition right by uh
the french guy leotard because that's a
pretty short book and i'm pretty sure a
big theme in that is language games is
it not
he does discuss witkenstein a lot yeah i
mean there's also anna lambija who wrote
a pretty influential book uh describing
wikenstein as the kind of peak
anti-philosopher
that's just that's just an idea because
i know it's a pretty short book and like
it might be uh
i wouldn't mind revisiting it yeah that
sounds good i don't like this i don't
like that characterization that he's
anti-philosophy because he obviously is
not um and i can't i can't really recall
badger's argument but he said he's one
of the three great anti-philosophers
but what wittgenstein said is philosophy
has a purpose it's just not what almost
all philosophers think it is which is
we're explaining something we're not
trying to explain something we're trying
to clarify problems but most of the time
philosophy just makes problems out of
nothing because they're they're not
referencing outside of their discipline
they're trying to
uh procrustently force language to do
something that language just does not do
they're using a wrong tool
yeah i mean it there is a certain sense
in which his in which philosophy during
this period is
conceived in a very very narrow right
right because you do think of philosophy
as
you know we think of philosophy as a
kind of
set of statements about a way of life a
world view something like bigger right
like what's your philosophy man like
like what's your philosophy about life
versus this version of philosophy which
is which is
very very narrowly focused on clarifying
the meaning of words cambridge
philosophy
and philosophy is almost like a
handmaiden that runs around and cleans
up the messes that all the other
disciplines are making out of language
because that's you know that's what you
get with the philosophy focused on
language
as opposed to philosophy in a broader
sense right because remember this is the
era
or well wittgenstein came up in the era
of very stringent anti-metaphysics right
you metaphysics is the enemy it must go
like what is it the big positivist aj ir
writes in the right in the beginning of
the book the the destruction of
metaphysics or whatever it's gotta go
because all we need is logical analysis
you mean logic truth and method
yeah yeah the first section of that book
is is just saying why metaphysics is
kind of should be
cast out of philosophy and so that it
does there is a certain narrowing down
of what philosophy is during this period
that i can
sympathize with as being you know a
little bit again deflationary you know
treating truth is just a function of the
meaning of words and context
as opposed to capital t truth which is
something that's supposed to be
universal and unchanging and guide our
lives right we gotta
aim for the truth we gotta draw the bow
and hold it taut and aim it at truth and
follow through but we can't do that if
truth is outside of philosophy or if you
know science is the province that
verifies whether the cat is in fact on
the mat or not
right i don't know i think that you
don't have to approach wickenstar from
this depletionary viewpoint and i'm also
not really convinced by kripke's
hyperskeptical interpretation of them
even though i think it's very
interesting i tend to think that like
terry eagleton and brandom's
hegelian materialist interpretation of
wickenstein is my favorite uh because
they say look you know in both hagel and
marks you find this idea that your sense
of selfhood is very much dependent upon
other people because you have to be
associated uh and
a given culture
that includes inheriting the language
through which that culture
articulates its worldview and its
description of the world and that
language is also vital in a hegelian
sense for you being able to articulate
who you are because you inherit words
like i or matt or myself or i feel or
whatever it happens to be right uh and
in this sense i see
wittenstein
as
proudly kind of
the most modern and clear exponent of a
very kind of german position that has an
auspicious history in the 19th century
and he might have approached it from a
bit more of a
relaxed viewpoint in the end but there
are definitely ways that you can say
extraordinarily radical and interesting
things with it like hegel and marks did
if you wanted to push his view far
enough oh there's definitely a basis for
that kind of interpretation because
again i think another way you could
describe wittgenstein's trajectory is
that he moves away from a correspondence
theory of truth and his early work
and moves towards a coherentist
philosophy of truth in his later work
right because it's no longer about you
know our pictures corresponding with
states of things it's about language
games being autonomous and
self-sufficient they're they're
consistent with themselves
they may they're not but they're
untranslatable in a sense into other
language games so you get this coherence
this coherentist theory of truth which i
believe is due to some kind of
interposition of of hegelian and
idealist ideas in cambridge during the
1920s
i mean that's not just speculative he
makes that statement exactly and
uncertainty where he says language
consists of a vast web or vast network
depending on how it's translated and you
can't kind of chisel off any part of it
and talk about
this game in isolation from all the
others
because they do have a family
resemblance to others that can allow you
to
not kind of reduce one game to another
but allow you to understand or enter
into one of the games knowing that you
at least understand a little bit because
you're familiar with some of the other
things that are adjacent to it right so
we imaginatively kind of carve off
language games in order to learn more
about
language overall but in a sense it's a
system it's a social thing
it exists in a totality
and beyond any language game is always a
form of life that corresponds to it
right like being a football player is
being a form of life and it contains
certain language games that are
autonomous and self-sufficient but it's
still a big fabric that extends beyond
those games but
i guess the the reason he says you know
imagine the builder game for example and
there's two builders and one of them
calls out block or or hammer and the
other one goes and gets the hammer
because they kind of know the rules of
the game and they deliver the object
that's a little that's a little
primitive he calls a primitive language
game we we imagine we carve them up like
that but really in reality these
language games are a kind of totality
a kind of like so surya and longage
almost right in a sense he kind of got
what he wanted i think because the way
that we talk about philosophy is very
rarely in that narrow
correspondence theory of truth sense
anymore we call we call marx marxism a
philosophy
when it's like
mostly economics we call psychoanalysis
philosophy when it's you know not
definitely not about it's
its goal is therapeutic not truth so i
think if you if you look at the way that
we describe philosophy i guess we call
it theory
often too on this podcast
but he kind of got he kind of got the
wish that this would
break into
different games and you know some people
might say this is the only way to see it
some people might say this is the only
way to see it but it's all blended a
little bit yeah and i would also like to
say because an episode wouldn't be
enough so without me blaming
neoliberalism for everything uh i do
think there is a political connotation
to this because once you realize uh that
our best all right i'm afraid that's all
we have time for right now
once you realize that a vision of truth
is coherent
and that a lot of who we think we are is
dependent upon other people you can
understand all the different ways that
communication can be vastly distorted uh
under the alienated conditions of modern
neoliberalism so if we want our true
wickenstone paradise uh where forms of
life are allowed to persist uh
with people engaged in democratic and
loving association with one another then
the number one thing that you should
take from the philosophical
investigations is neoliberalism needs to
be smashed as quickly as possible
i wonder
if we had another time for another
episode i would want to like go around
and figure out
how realist everybody in here is
as opposed to probably obsessed
that'd be fun the only realistic option
is smashing neoliberalism
pills you know that
the only thing we should be talking
about until we smash neoliberalism is
how to smash neoliberalism and then we
can talk about all the other things that
we want to
oh and in a sense i think both of these
views he adopts are both forms of
anti-realism in a way um but i'm not
quite clear on it because it you have to
talk about you know is it naive realism
we're talking about or scholastic
realism or critical realism there's a
lot of
i mean there's some clarifications that
need to happen so we don't again
cross-language games again
yeah i mean realism to me is just one of
those terms that you throw use when you
want to
pay homage to a certain viewpoint
because i would say we can sign in many
senses
as very skeptical in some respects but
very realistic in others since as pills
likes to say he is continuously pointing
to the world of everyday life and saying
don't get caught up in all these
intellectualized abstractions always
start from asking the dude at the bar
for a miller light uh or how
a bricklayer is talking to his
apprentice and teaching them how to lay
bricks or how two people are playing
chess in a park you start there and then
you move forward and we do not endorse
the drinking of miller lite
ever
yeah i'd also be interested to be better
than that listeners don't drink miller
light
drink miller high life
being a critical theory podcast it would
be interesting to compare his approach
to critical theory
possibly of of derrida and difference
because i get the sense that
they both start in very very different
places but they
you know they they maybe have similar
things to say
you know you have you have
derrida's critique which usually starts
out very close to somebody's text like
the sosurian text and then like kind of
works out the contradictions
versus
wittgenstein who seems to just be
writing his own text and bringing
examples quite often it's a very
different method
they seem to be but they seem to both be
social philosophy in a certain way well
this is the kind of connection that i
would draw again between the tractatus
and the philosophical investigations
because the tractatus is again sometimes
presented as
a
seri up
the ultimate form of logical
argumentation right where you move step
by step from one proposition from
proposition one down to proposition
seven and if you buy the initial
premises everything kind of flows except
at the end again he has this remarkable
statement where he says the weird thing
is if you buy into the philosophy that i
was just talking about you'd realize
that all the statements i make aren't
concurrent with what i just said
so there's a self-swallowing kind of
quality to this because all i can do is
demonstrate to you uh how it is that you
can think this way i can't actually show
you
in the pictorial way that i've described
as the only consistent approach to truth
and you do see something similar to that
in the philosophical investigations
where he doesn't sit there and start by
saying
i'm going to provide you with my theory
of social reality and language and then
we'll move from there to some examples
he says
i can only show you the way to think
about this through examples as paul said
like 60 of them or so just these
unbelievable numbers of them and once
you see enough of them you'll start to
get the right idea and again you'll
realize all the kind of therapeutic
implications that he's trying to
get you uh to appreciate there's some of
his books that i've never read and never
got to like he wrote a book about color
i think and one about psychology
i mean that'd be interesting
i i
very rarely see him cited you know these
days
well interestingly that essay on color
is one of the only other things that he
published in his lifetime in addition to
the tractatus and apparently
a small
book
for school children
but he says at that point that his views
on the picture theory of language were
starting to change because he wasn't
exactly sure how it is that the picture
theory of language could account for
color as color right i could account for
it in terms of wavelength but that
doesn't seem to get at what we called in
an earlier essay
you know the qualia of seeing red or
seeing blue
right yeah the actual sense impressions
yeah and i mean that's a very
interesting point because
you know you don't really think seeing
red or seeing blue is really all that
important but apparently it stimulated
him to say like there's something really
weird with my picture theory of language
because color is essential to any
picture
except for black and white one i guess
or the most pictures and yet i can't
seem to account for that here so yeah
maybe there's a problem and then
again nothing until you get the things
that become problems for him are very
strange
like the middle finger made him go reef
someone giving him the the finger made
him rethink his uh whole philosophy
oh [ __ ] i just came into color i gotta
throw the book and start again
how is there a hippopotamus in this room
i don't know that there's not
yeah but i could never be searched for
he was also weird in the sense that
he had
i think somewhat self-consciously like
anti-bourgeois
values in terms of his own personal
habits because
as eric was saying at the beginning he
grew up in like a mega rich family that
considered itself kind of
high brow liberal
in the period where you know vienna was
many ways like at the center of austria
and even european civilization you know
sigmund freud a variety of different
people were kind of pioneering and
breaking down taboos
but in terms of wickenstein's own taste
he almost seemed to try to cultivate
this
quasi-proletarian sensibility uh like
apparently he
hated um
movies that aspired to be excessively
artistic uh he really liked westerns
that's what he liked to watch right
cowboy movies
yeah today he would probably be going to
see every bit of marvel trash and saying
isn't that exciting and isn't that good
and if he was watching like a guitar
film he'd be like oh you know that
pretentious [ __ ] hacks authenticity
and integrity he's just so far removed
from everyday life and would have none
of it right
it's hard to make sense of his
personality loved beethoven
i think he was a bit ashamed that he
wasn't musical i think a lot of his
family was very musically talented and
he was worried in his youth that he
didn't have any talents he didn't know
what he was going to do with his life
and then he then he discovered that he
was pretty good at philosophy under
burch and russell so
did you ever hear how bertrand russell
described him he's like i saw this young
man who came up to me and he sat there
and he's like i need you to tell me
immediately if i am a complete idiot
because if i am a complete idiot then i
shall become an aeronautical mechanic
but if i am not a complete idiot i shall
do a philosophy so i told him to write
me something over the summer break and
upon reading the first sentence i said
you are clearly not a complete idiot you
should absolutely become a philosophy
well then
the rest of that story though is
wittgenstein wrote a critique of
russell's work i think he asked him to
even but he wrote a critique of his of
his work and russell's response was
i saw that i could never again have a
hope of doing anything in philosophy for
the rest of my life yeah just upsetting
right and the weird thing about it too
is he really was
a kind of prodigy in a lot of senses
because apparently
again he had these weird kind of
anti-bourgeois sensibilities because if
you asked a lot of like cambridge
philosophers
or people today academic philosophers
how they approach their job
you know they'd say it's my nine to five
you know i wake up i read a couple
journal articles i write a little bit i
go to a conference and that's how i do
things uh and you know you gotta read
and keep up with the literature and read
all the important secondary sources
apparently he barely read any work of
philosophy you know there's that scandal
that he had never even bothered to read
aristotle's or again on or any of the
kind of classical works of logic he read
a little bit of russell a little bit of
frega as eric said you know some william
james but he didn't even really like
professional philosophy all that much
and yet he was very very gifted added
and he despised idiots
he went to teach i think he was in
austria he went to teach in this village
and he wrote a letter to
i think russell might have been someone
else but he wrote a letter and he's like
the people here are 25 animal
and he eventually had to flee the town
because he was like brutally beating the
children that he was supposed to be
teaching in like high school and it sent
a kid to the hospital and made like this
girl's ears bleed and then they were
gonna call the cops on him and he just
skipped town and left
well this is the thing yeah i really
think he wanted to kind of cultivate
this proletarian
sensibility i mean as eric was pointing
out there's that other period where he
wanted to go to the soviet union and
apparently when he petitioned to go they
were like yeah we'll give you a position
anywhere you want like you know your
famous western philosopher if you
convert to the soviet system that's a
fantastic coup for us and he's like no
no i just want to do like backpacking i
want to work in a car like all the
people
and they were like no no no we can't
have you doing that because that'll just
make us look worse it's like the first
thing we did when we can sign arrive is
set him to the gulag or something like
could it be an important philosopher or
nothing he's like well
not into that then bro
but he just had like this kind of weird
back and forth sometimes between
his aristocratic and elitist tendencies
coming out and just trying to
desperately
militate against them sometimes to the
point where he seems to have been torn
over that like he has been wasn't for so
many things he's a fascinating guy
and we haven't brought this up yet but
he's kind of a snack too
what do you mean that's good-looking
nice dark features
he does yeah and apparently unlike
nietzsche he did actually have like
genuine friendships like nietzsche had
this bad habit of
taking friends and turning them into
enemies uh
marx was gifted at that also but like
wittgenstein's buddies sometimes found
him like difficult to deal with and
they're sometimes just like you gotta
[ __ ] like calm down like not
everything needs to be like ratcheted up
to a 20. but yeah very intense guy yeah
but like
keynes and russell kind of remained
friends with him on and off for uh this
entire life and his students worshipped
him and
apparently he did actually have genuine
proletariat friends which he was very
proud of go see westerns with them and
you know if they want to talk about
philosophy and when he was living on
that shack i think in ireland i wanted
to go visit it when i was living there
apparently like all the farmers in the
region liked him he'd go to the bar
but none of them knew who he was because
he would never talk about it and he
found that enjoyable
his his proletarian accessories
yeah he volunteered at a hospital at one
point maybe during the second war and he
and nobody knew who he was and he didn't
tell anybody and he was just
volunteering and then he ended up doing
some amazing stuff like designing a new
machine for pumping blood or something
like that
and then they they kind of ask oh who
are you i'm vickenstein oh you mean the
wickenstein from cambridge he's like yep
that's the one like he was very
weirdly humble sometimes just didn't
again that's that asceticism coming
through he just didn't want
worldly possessions he didn't want fame
he didn't want money he didn't want
anything he just wanted a shack where he
could just write and be happy and
so somewhat alone
but he also didn't want to be surrounded
by idiots yeah
phil's saying yeah he had difficulty
with that and i mean it takes real balls
when you're in your 20s to write an 80
page book and say i've solved all the
problems of philosophy
none of you have anything to do anymore
so
i'm just going to retire and
teach school children because that's a
more valuable enterprise than actually
assuming
the
a cambridge position teaching philosophy
to undergraduates no point in that right
it's just
you can only imagine how that must have
pissed people off
kind of a weird
combination of ascetic and megalomaniac
called called mozart and and beethoven
sons of god
weird weird language to use for a guy
who's supposedly an atheist but you know
who knows he was seemed kind of
spiritual at the same time
well we made it pretty far through this
i think that was uh
as good of an intro as any
yeah so we'll say yeah bye with that and
thank you to the listeners and thank the
three of you
and uh yeah catch us next week
glad to learn about this topic
all right guys that was fun
good talk see you next time it was
efficient
[Music]